if you were worried that Ubisoft's third
person sword fighting game for honor may
not have a single payer component he or
not while the details are still sparse
developer Ubisoft Montreal has confirmed
the game will have a single-player
component in a Ubisoft reduce video
producer Stefan card and said quote one
of the big questions you receive is
about a solo campaign and I can promise
you that we will have a solo campaign
although Ubisoft isn't quite ready to
reveal anything substantial carden went
on to say that quote it's one of the key
subjects we're working on on the floor I
can't wait to show stuff to you guys and
we'll do it as early as possible like we
did with the multiplayer for honor was
unveiled at last year's e3 at which time
it appeared to be a multiplayer centric
game that may still prove to be the case
but you apparently won't be forced to
play the game with other people 400 is
scheduled to hit playstation 4 xbox one
and pc later this year when we find out
more about the game's single-player
you'll be the first to know